ANKUR KOTWAL: So, before we get
started into this week's
topic, let's talk
about the news.
So, really two pieces of news
for Android developers.
Firstly, Google Play Services
has launched.
We're really excited
about this.
It now provides the OAuth
identity management.
It provides you OAuth tokens so
that you can use a single
nice API that abstracts the
whole OAuth side of things for
you across all of our
Google services.
And we also have the Google+
SDK as part of that.
So Google Play Services
is quite interesting.
What it is, is it's a component
that's actually
going to be there on users'
devices as part of the Google
Play Store.
The Google Play Services
component will be installed.
And now, as developers, you can
just go ahead and start
using that new API.
This is just the start of
something much bigger.
Google Play Services
will grow.
And OAuth2 and Google+
are finally here.
So that's really good.
And the other thing that I'm
really excited about is that
we have a new build system
coming for the Android
developer tools.
Akim Zaveidurisham has put up
a document that sort of
describes some of the changes
that are coming up.
They're not available in a
stable release yet, but you
can certainly go and have a look
at that document and see
what kind of changes
are coming.
Yeah, this is good stuff.
More tools for developers
is always a good thing.
It's tablet week, so our focus
today is to really use the
word "tablet" as much
as possible.
No, that's not true.
We want to basically empower
developers to build apps that
work well on phones
and tablets.
We're actually going to have a
series of presentations on
ADL+ over the coming weeks.
Today's the first one, and
it's really about the
fundamental building blocks
of these apps.
And it's really Fragments--
those are the components
that you use.
So today is very much a
primer on Fragments.
And so we're going to
cover a few things.
But before we do, let's talk
about some fundamental goals
that developers would
like to have, or we
always want to have.
We want to build phone
and tablet apps.
Firstly, we want to have
a single app for
multiple form factors.
We don't want to have to manage
a different set of code
for a phone version, for a
tablet version, or even for a
Google TV version.
As much as possible we want to
maximize our code reuse.
And in doing so, you kind of
want to have your code be
quite decoupled so that you
can build these reusable
components and have them not
totally depend on the other
components being there.
Decoupling is obviously a really
good thing in general
software design.
And finally, you want to build
these apps such that they're
backward compatible.
Android 3.0, or Honeycomb,
is where we
first introduced tablets.
And prior to that, we had
Gingerbread and Froyo.
Now Gingerbread is still
a very popular
version of the platform.
So when we talk about these
Fragments and utilizing them,
we want to do it in a way that
still allows our apps to run
on these older versions.
So we're going to touch
on that, too.
How do we make sure that they're
backward compatible,
whilst keeping all of
these goals in mind?
So, what are Fragments?
Fragments--
they're really reusable
components.
So it's about grouping bits of
your UI, or other common
functionality, so that you
can then use it in these
standalone classes.
So, when we think about taking
an app and making it available
on tablets, what we want to do
is really promote the idea of
the fact that you should
really rethink your UI.
Don't just take your phone
layout and stretch it because
that's not really a
good experience.
And in the majority of cases,
stretching out a typical list
or something like that on a
phone and just stretching it
out onto a tablet doesn't really
result in a good user
experience.
And users never tend
to appreciate that.
So, as you can see from this
diagram here, where you might
have had two activities--
one and two--
what you would do is actually
take the contents of those
activities, and put them
into Fragment.
And on the phone, you would be
showing one Fragments at a
time, whereas on the tablet you
could show both Fragments
at a time within a
single Activity.
So the Activity is still that
outer window, and you can see
it based on the blue border.
You still have activities
when you're running
on phones and tablets.
And we're not moving away
from activities.
But we are taking out all of
that code that we had within
the Activity, around the user
interface, and just regrouping
it into Fragments.
So what are Fragments?
Well, Fragments are basically
reusable UI components.
By grouping our contents that
we would have had in an
Activity, it means
that we can be
flexible with these Fragments.
Being a Fragments isn't
just like an
include in your layout.
There's actually more
to it than that.
It actually participates as
part of the life cycle.
So Fragments actually
have a life cycle.
And they're attached
to an Activity.
And that's really important
because the Activity will
initialize them at key points.
It'll populate them.
And there are some specific
overloads that you
should be aware of.
Fragments can also maintain
their own backstack.
So, in a typical phone app, you
might go from one Activity
to the next, to the next.
But if you now start reusing
the contents of those
activities into Fragments, you
might use a single Activity
and just transition from one
Fragment to the next.
Now when the user hits the
"Back" button, you don't want
it to go from one Activity to
the previous one, you want to
make sure you navigate backwards
through the Fragment
stack before you go to the
previous Activity.
So, Fragments allow this.
The other thing to keep in mind
is that Fragments don't
have to be UI components.
They can just be background
workers that you instantiate
and that participate as part
of the life cycle.
So, we have an API called
findFragmentByTag.
Typically what you'd have is a
Fragment that you'd put in a
layout, and you'd do a find
view by ID, and grab the
layout, and so on
and so forth.
But you can actually instantiate
Fragments.
In using the Fragment manager,
you cannot basically name
them, or tag them.
So this find Fragment by tag
is a way to basically get a
hold of that Fragment at runtime
without having to rely
on things like the
view hierarchy.
So, let's talk a little bit
about Fragments and activities
in general.
So, the user interface
part is optional.
Typically, in most
circumstances, you would use
them with a user interface.
You would use them
for grouping UI.
But you don't have to.
Whereas with an Activity, it
always has a user interface.
It's always the part
that the user sees.
Both of them tend to have
life cycle methods.
And in fact, the Fragment tends
to have a few more life
cycle methods than the Activity
in the typical UI
style Fragment.
Fragments can't be standalone.
They are attached
to activities.
And we actually have
an override called
onAttach and onDetach.
Now, the other thing you should
be aware of is the use
of Intents.
So typically we use Intents to
invoke certain pieces of
functionality in
your Activity.
That still holds true, except
with Fragments, Intents don't
go fire up Fragments directly.
You have to go through
an Activity.
And we're going to clarify
this later.
So what we're doing here
is best describing
what Fragments are.
We're going to look at now the
advantages of using Fragments.
And then eventually we
will talk about--
before we talk about
backwards support--
we're going to talk about
communication, as well,
between Fragments.
So let's look at a
typical layout.
On a phone, this is the people
app that we've had since Ice
Cream Sandwich.
And you'll see on the
left hand side
you've got a list view.
With this list view you have
your list of contacts there,
and there's some tabs
across the top.
You can swipe across
them and so on.
It's a fairly standard list
view type screen with some
actions along the bottom.
Now, if we want to click Matias
there, it would take us
from the list view for
that contact and go
into the detail view.
Now, a traditional phone app may
have implemented these as
Activity 1 one for the list view
and Activity 2 for the
detail view.
But if we then reorganize our
code such that this list view
part of it becomes a Fragment,
and the detailed view also
becomes a Fragment, then what
happens is on the phone we
still can still present
the same interface.
But when we go something like
the tablet, we can show these
multiple Fragments
at the same time.
We're maximizing
our code reuse.
We're not having to define
layouts multiple times, and
even code multiple times,
or having really complex
inheritance hierarchies.
With Fragments, we can basically
show multiple pieces
of UI at the same time.
There is some extra code that
you need to do to distinguish
between a phone layout
and a tablet layout.
We're going to look
at that next.
But the differences are really
phenomenal in terms of the
overhead for you and
your developers.
So, when it comes to defining
layouts, you might be saying,
well, how can I say that this
layout is going to be for a
phone or for a tablet?
Well, in Eclipse, when you
define your resource or your
layout directories, you can
basically say it's a layout
directory, which will be the
default layout that gets used.
Or you can have these
extra qualifiers.
So, one of the qualifiers is
something that we call
smallest width.
And then you can specify
a number and a DP.
Now, smallest width basically
says, that regardless of
whether I'm holding it in
portrait or landscape view,
what is the smallest dimension
on this device?
Now, what we've done is that
we've got some metrics in
there that tell you that this
is the range of values that
will result in a tablet
UI, or phone UI.
So, if you specify smallest
width 600, anything that has
600 DPs or greater is considered
a tablet, okay?
We've, in fact, added
an extra layer of
differentiation there.
If you specify 600 DP,
it'll get picked up
by seven inch tablets.
If you specify 720 DP, it'll
actually get picked up by 10
inch tablets.
So you may want to have a
different layout between your
seven inch tablets, and
your 10 inch tablets.
And this metric here
is how you do that.
And you'd still have a
normal layout folder.
And That normal layout folder is
what will get picked up or
phones, the 600 DP for seven
inch tablets, and the 720 DP
for 10 inch tablets.
You don't have to
have all three.
Nothing is sort of forcing
you to do so, but our
recommendation is at
least have two.
Have the default layout folder,
and then have the 600
DP for your tablet UI.
Now prior to Android 3.2--
so really only Android
3.0 and 3.1--
the only way that you could have
a tablet layout was to
specify a res-large or a res.
Sorry, that should say
layout-large and
layout-xlarge directory.
In fact, I'm going to just
fix that live right
now, because I can.
And we're done.
So, it's a layout-large and
a layout-xlarge directory
because prior to Android 3.2,
we didn't have that smallest
width qualifier.
So, a large or and extra large
layout would actually get
picked up by those devices.
We no longer recommend that you
use large and extra large
qualifiers because it becomes
a little bit of a gray area.
What defines a large, screen?
Is it a seven inch tablet,
like the Nexus 7?
Or is something like
a Galaxy Note
considered a large screen?
So, rather than having these
generic buckets, we now use
the smallest width qualifier
and you should, too.
So, at run time, how would you
tell between whether you're
running in a phone layout,
or tablet layout?
Well it's easy, right?
Because in your Activity you're
going to have a layout
that you load.
And on the phone, you would
typically only be showing one
Fragment at a time.
On a tablet, you might
show more than
one tablet at a time.
So, what you can do is use a
findViewById API, and see if
you can find both Fragments.
For example, if you're going
to be able to find one
Fragment, then you know that
you're running on a phone.
If you're able to find both
Fragments, then you know that
you're running on a tablet.
And so that's that extra sort
of glue code that I was
talking to.
But it really belongs
in your Activity.
Because remember, Fragments
themselves should be
standalone, reusable components
that are fairly
decoupled from everything
else.
It's the Activity that kind of
binds the multiple friends, or
really your layout
that binds the
multiple Fragments together.
So, you can just use a trick
like that with using
findViewById and doing
a null check.
And that should sort you out.
So, we talked about
Intents before.
Typically what happens is when
an Intents gets fired off,
your Activity gets invoked and
told hey, here's an Intents.
But you can't go from Intents
directly to a Fragment.
It still comes through
an Activity.
So, you might be wondering,
well, how do I manage that?
How do I get an Intents to end
up invoking a Fragment?
And the answer is it has to
go through an Activity.
But let me just show you some
code that demonstrates how
that propagation may work.
So let me just highlight
the relevant section.
So, here what's happened
is we're in the--
it could happen in onCreate
or it could happen on
onNewIntents--
what you'd do is basically
do a get Intents code.
So this code is actually in your
Activity, itself, right?
And so we just do
a get Intents.
We get the action.
And we're just comparing whether
the Intents action
matches whatever action it is
that we're interested in.
So, once we do that in our
Activity, we can then go, OK I
know that it is this action.
So now I'm going to
go and get a hold
off my noteless Fragment.
So in this Activity there's
probably a list Fragment and a
detail Fragment.
So a list of notes, and then
the detail Fragment is
probably the note itself.
So, what we did is we
got the Intents.
Now we managed to pull the
relevant Fragment out.
And then finally we are able
to pass in some extra
information.
Or, sorry, from the Intents we
can get some extra information
out as to which list item
we want to select, or
so on and so forth.
But this is an example of
where in the Activity we
receive the Intents and then we
followed that through and
passed it through the
relevant Fragment.
So we are kind of starting to
spread out our code a little
bit between different classes.
But that's not necessarily
a bad thing, either.
OK, so we talked about Intents
communication, but what about
when you've got two Fragments
and you want to communicate
with one another?
You could do all sorts of sort
of trickery, where you've got
Fragments talking
to Fragments.
But it's generally not a good
thing because then you start
to really closely couple
them together.
Then one Fragment needs to
know whether the other
Fragment exists, and has been
loaded, and so on and so
forth, and then pass information
back and forth.
Instead, what we recommend, is
you still use the Activity as
kind of a proxy.
So, what you would do to achieve
Fragment to Fragment
communication is go
via the Activity.
So, here you'll see that what
we recommended is that you
define an interface
in Fragment 1--
we're calling it Interface
A for now.
Then Fragment 2 would have
Interface B defined.
The Activity would implement
those methods.
And then when those methods
are being called on those
interfaces, it would
then pass it on to
the relevant Fragment.
And it may, in fact, like on
a phone, actually need to
instantiate the second
Fragment.
Because on a phone, both
Fragments may not have been
instantiated, because
that single
Fragment layout uploaded.
So, again really the Activity's
that thing that's
binding it all together,
right?
So what would happen is that
once the interfaces are
defined and the Activity's
implementing them, your
Fragments are invoking the
Activity, and then the
Activity in turn is calling
the Fragment.
So let's look at some code
that demonstrates that.
So, onAttach is within
a Fragment.
That's an overload.
Sorry, that's an override that
says that your Fragment has
been attached to a particular
Activity.
That's when it gets called.
So when our Fragment gets
attached to an Activity, we're
just storing that Activity as
a callback object within the
Fragment, itself.
And you'll notice that the type
of that callback object
is this note list
event callback.
That's our interface, which is
at the bottom of this page.
But we'll talk about
that in a minute.
But anyway, we store
it as an interface.
And then on our Fragment, in
this unlist item click method,
when we need to go and do
something about the fact that
the user has selected something,
we then can do it
one of two ways.
We can just call "get Activity",
and then go call
the do something method.
Or we can use the interface,
itself, which we stored as a
callback object, onAttach
method.
Now, my personal preference
is to use the callback.
I think it's cleaner.
We've defined clear
interfaces.
So again we're kind
of decoupling
our code quite nicely.
So, you'd call
callback.onListClicked(id).
Now remember we talked about at
the start in this onAttach
method, we stored this callback,
and we said it had
to implement an interface.
Well that's what this bit
at the bottom is.
It's the interface that this
Fragment is defining.
To say, hey, whichever object I
need to sort of inform that
a particular action is taken,
that object will obviously
implement this method, itself.
And will pass a note ID,
or whatever it may be.
So, communication between
Fragments--
don't do it directly from
Fragment to Fragment.
Have a proxy layer, and that's
typically the Activity.
Because the Activity is the
thing that Fragments are
attached to.
So, we talked about some nice
things here, but I also
mentioned that Fragments
came into Android 3.0.
The good news is that we
actually introduced Fragments
in the support library.
So, the support library
is a reusable library.
You may have heard me
mention it before.
It's really simple to include
in your project.
Within Eclipse, you just right
click the project, go to
Android Tools, and say,
add support library.
It will go and download
the latest version.
Include the jar on your project,
and set up the
[INAUDIBLE]
as well.
And the name space is
then available.
So, we basically put backward
compatible Fragments in the
support library.
Now, my recommendation to
developers is use the support
Fragments from the start.
Any time you're building a new
app, start with Fragments.
Think about tablets and phones
as effectively being first
class citizens.
Try not to start with a phone
app, and then migrate to a
tablet app later.
You may choose to do the tablet
side of things later
on, but at least set up the
infrastructure and start using
Fragments from the
very beginning.
Because it's a lot easier
then to manage a tablet
version of your app.
Whereas if you don't use
Fragments, and then later on
you have to go and reorganize
all of your activities, and so
on, into Fragments, the overhead
is a lot more later
on because you've got
a big chunk of code
that you need to refactor.
So, the support library
has Fragments.
And one other really important
piece of advice is don't mix
and match support Fragments with
the native Fragments that
you'll find on Android
3.0 and upwards.
They're different
implementation.
They're different classes.
So you kind of mix and match
a support Fragment
and a native Fragment.
But we are able to achieve
backward compatibility.
And that is how all of our
internal apps work, as well.
You've noticed I showed you
the people app, which is
obviously an Ice Cream
Sandwich app.
Even things like Gmail.
Gmail uses multiple Fragments.
Anyways, so that's backward
compatibility.
And that's a bit of a
primer on Fragments.
So let's move on to Q&A. Does
anyone on the thread here have
any questions on today's topic,
or even otherwise?
I'm just going to look
at the thread.
It doesn't look like there's
been any question posted.
There's a question that says
are you going to share this
presentation after
the session?
And the answer is yes.
It's available on YouTube
because the recording goes up
and it'll be there.
So you can go and view it
at any point in time.
Alright, so there's no
questions there.
My colleague Anirudh is joining
us from Hyderabad.
Anriudh, should we move
to Google Moderator?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yes, thanks
for the [INAUDIBLE]
Ankur.
So, let's take a few questions
in Moderator.
The first one, and I'm going
to read it loud.
"My music player app (audio
streaming) should work while
I'm driving in a car
with 3G card.
What the API features should
I consider as a developer?
The player apps work excellent
with Wi-Fi, and some of the
devices with 3G." Ankur, do
you wanna take that up?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, sure.
Look, in general, there is no no
specific API that you want
to use to differentiate your
behavior, your app's behavior.
But there's some strategy.
So, with 3G, it's not a good
idea to continually
have the radio on.
As much as possible you want to
prefetch and chunk it up.
If you can do that when you're
on Wi-Fi, that's even better.
But streaming and asking for
chunks, or buffers, of data
periodically is probably not
the best way to do it.
Because it will have a
significant drain on the
user's device.
So yeah, prefetching is
one really good thing.
Rater Meyer, our colleague,
presented at
Google I/O this year.
And the talk was making
good apps great.
So check it out.
There's some great advice
in there on how to
achieve some of this.
But what you can do to work out
whether you are connected
to Wi-Fi, or 3G, is use the
connectivity manager.
And then change your behavior
accordingly.
And also keep in mind that if
you are pulling down lots of
data, prefetch can be one of
those sensitive things.
Just make sure the user's
OK with you doing that.
It's a music player,
you said, right?
So if the user has 2 GB of
music, you probably don't want
to download that on their
3G connection.
Because you are going to blow
through their data limit.
Wi-Fi is typically better.
Most people are OK with Wi-Fi.
But again, you need to consider
their data limits on
Wi-FI and tune your behavior
accordingly.
Also, the last thing is if you
are sort of prefetching and
caching, just keep in mind how
large your cache is becoming.
You might want to manage that.
You might want to have some
maximal threshold set on the
app, itself, so that you're not
using up all of the user's
storage capacity.
Is there anything else you
want to add, Anirudh?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah, so, he
also asked, what API features
should I consider
as a developer?
So, for the music app, the two
things I would recommend are
play approach from the rich
notification bar.
This is where you handle
your users.
And also Lock Screen Wizard if
you have your controls there.
Because if somebody's driving
a car with a 3G card, or
playing with Wi-Fi, you don't
want him to unlock the phone
and go in and stop your
music, or do whatever.
So the Lock Screen Wizard and
notification bar controls bar
controls are really good.
Those are a couple of API
features you should look at.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Actually, also the
Bluetooth Music Controls.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So, we've got APIs
around that so you can
respond to buttons on people's
Bluetooth headset, so when
they say "Play, Pause,
Next Song".
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Alright,
thanks for that update.
So, the next question is, "I'm
trying to make an app using
Connectivity API.
Is it communication between
devices, or is it between
applications?
What is the primary connectivity
devices or
applications?
What is the security layer?
Is it on app level or device
level?" So, I recently gave a
talk on Connectivity API,
dealing [INAUDIBLE].
I think the question is sort
of coming from there, as a
follow-up question.
So I'd like to answer this.
So when we say Connectivity API,
what we really mean is
wireless API is like Wi-Fi and
Google and being which it
would use to communicating
between devices, and also with
the Cloud like Wi-Fi.
So is it communication between
devices or between
applications?
So, it's really a combination
between devices, but we've got
some app level features
that you can use.
For example, with Wi-Fi direct,
I talked about using
Service Discovery, which is
an app level feature.
So, if your app is using Wi-Fi
direct to connect with another
device, these are available as
framework compliments just
like telephony manager and
network connectivity manager.
You have a Wi-Fi peer-to-peer
manager available in your app
when you extend [INAUDIBLE].
And you can use this Wi-Fi P2P
manager to discover other
services around the
[INAUDIBLE].
So the connection is really
between the devices because
it's Wi-Fi, but then your
application has some extra
features from the framework
available on top of which you
can write your application.
And the same goes for
security layers.
So if you're using Wi-Fi direct,
for example, you have
options to use something for the
framework which is like a
key-based authentication or
you just use a pin-based
authentication, the general
wireless security options
available to you.
But on top of that you build
something on your app as well.
You could ask for pin codes
or you could ask for user
accounts, or--
And that same goes for
[INAUDIBLE] and other
Connectivity APIs.
So [INAUDIBLE], we provide
core infrastructure of
security and data transfer
using APIs at the device
level, at the framework level.
And on top of that, we give you
some more flexibility in
terms of what input.
So, Ankur, would you like to
add something to that?
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, I think that
was quite comprehensive.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Alright.
Okay, the next question
is, and this is
from Melbourne Jeff.
"I'm trying to use a searchView
in an action bar
and my theme is based on
Theme.Holo.Light.DarkActionBar.
I have an issue in which I
cannot find where to set the
color of the edit text
in the search view.
Can I use a custom layout
for the searchView?
So, I'm not really sure on
the answer for this one.
And I think the answer is that
the attributes available on
searchView are not customizable,
in the sense
that they are not stylable
attributes.
So if you need to change the
color, you probably would want
to wrap the view from the
layout during runtime.
Programmatically that is on PA
you would want to find the
view with the search-View
ID inside your onCreate.
And try to grab a reference
for the view.
And then verify the
properties on it.
By exploring the layout
final view
searchView, it's not simple.
What I can do is I'll send a
note to our UI team and see if
they have any suggestions on
what can be done here.
But I doubt if we can customize
the [INAUDIBLE]
using stylable attributes.
Alright, let's go to
the next question.
"Hi, I am a beginner in
Android development.
And I need some help about
getting information from an
URL and displayed in a good
UI." So, I think this is a
very basic question, a pretty
broad question.
So, in terms of displaying it
in a good UI, we have plenty
of UI conferences available
and some training classes
available at Android.com.
There are also a lot of patterns
and practices which
you could learn about
from developers at
Android.com/design.
We have some design guidelines
and how to build a good UI.
And some of those
sessions we've
covered in our last show.
So you could also visit
our playlist.
From Youtube go back and catch
up on some of those sessions.
So really, good UI is kind
of a broad question.
And there's a lot of resources
available on
our developer site.
And you can choose some
of these live shows.
When it comes to grabbing
information from a URL, so
what you would need is internet
permission on your
application, first thing.
And then you could use a
standard Java URL connection
APIs, which would allow you
to connect [INAUDIBLE]
and you could set the
appropriate headers
authentication Steam by
using URL connection.
And then download the data
as an HTTP response.
So that's the way
for doing it.
And one thing to note here
is that if you must use
Gingerbread, we recommend that
before she I'm going to
different people losing URL
connection there so that was
some issues with URL connection
client before
[INAUDIBLE].
So, if you are building an app
that's meant to be compatible
across the entire range of
devices, and it should be, you
should consider the fact.
If you look at the runtime,
you could look at the
build of the OS.
And then choose do
use a different
client to get the data.
So that's [INAUDIBLE]
client.
Are there any more resources
you'd like to point to?
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, just our
colleague David Chandler had
written a nice little library to
fetch information from the
net, basically passing
the URL.
And it just sort of abstracted
a lot of detail for you.
Yeah, look up David Chandler
on Google+.
And he's got a really nice
library that you can use.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Alright,
great.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I can take this
one. "Could you please
describe the best strategy for
working with Fragments and
loaders is in a map Activity?
Any plans of supporting
Fragments in a map Activity?"
So, the honest truth is it's
pretty difficult, right?
The map Activity is something
that we sort of released
fairly early on.
And it obviously provides the
map component part of it.
But it's not a traditional
Activity.
What you need is a Fragment
Activity from a support
library if you want
to use Fragments.
So in some ways, map Activity
and Fragment activities are
kind of divergent from
one another.
I've seen developers do
it with all sorts
of tricks and hacks.
But I also know that there's
been some complications in
having to do it that way.
We would love to be able to just
use maps in a Fragment.
We, as in Google, haven't
published anything yet.
It's actually a fairly common
request that we get.
And so, we are.
We're definitely looking
into it.
We don't have anything here to
announce from a map Fragment
point of view.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So, I think that
was the last question.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Just checking if
there's any other question on
the on-air thread, which there
doesn't seem to be.
Does anyone live have any other
questions before, or we
should wrap up, is the
other question?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So, I
think [? Balisabu ?]
from Bangalore who asked the
Connectivity API question I
thought we handled.
If you have other follow-up
questions, you could
ask us right now.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Alright, well
it doesn't look like it.
Maybe he's shy.
Or maybe he just doesn't have
any follow-up questions.
On that note, I guess
we'll head off.
Thank you for joining
us again.
And we'll be back same
time next week.
Thanks for joining.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Thank you.
Bye-bye.